let's make tonight the weekend I don't
want to wait it I don't want to wait it
I don't want to wait got no reason not
to celebrate it baby I just don't want
to
wait swimming in the deep blue got me
thinking about you I'm just trying to
Dive Right
In want to spend tonight like the last
night of our Lives chasing all the love
we can
and now oh I'm in a sea of lights and
all that I can see is you and now I'm
dying to feel of life so baby let's try
something new let's make tonight the
weend I don't want to wait I don't want
to wait I don't want to wait got no
reason not to celebrate it baby I just
don't want away tonight a weekend I
don't want to wait it I don't want to
wait it I don't want to wait got no
reason not to celebrate it baby I just
don't want
away I've been chasing so long every
right that feels wrong rather be with
you
instead there's something about it right
here got me seeing so clear rainbow
color Skies
Ahead now oh I'm in a sea of light and
all that I can see is you and now I'm
dying to feel life so baby let's try
something new let's make tonight the
weekend I don't want to wait I don't
want to wait I don't want to wait got
the reason not to celebrate it baby I
just don't want away tonight so we weend
I don't want to wait I don't want to
wait I don't want to wait got no reason
not to celebrate baby I just don't want
to wa it's been tonight the weekend I
don't want to wait I don't want to wait
I don't want to wait got no reason not
to celebrate baby I just don't want to
wait
hey friends I hope you enjoyed that flow
session goodness only knows I really
enjoyed creating it uh if you'd like to
get a hold of a set of these Flom moja
LED POI from flow toys that I was using
in this video uh you can do so by by
heading on over to flowtoys.com and
using the promo code drexfactor
92024 again that is drexfactor
9224 at checkout to get 10% off your
order of any prop in their online store
so flow toys thanks so much for
sponsoring this video and giving me an
excuse to go out and explore DC and flow
in it um I have some other thank yous to
put out there uh biggest one being to
the Friends of the channel uh big thanks
to dark monk flow fests flow toys Pyar
light toys and Ultra poy for helping to
make the videos on this channel possible
you can learn more about all of these
awesome companies by checking out the
links that I have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non- business friend of
the channel peka peek Glen thank you so
very much for supporting my channel my
work and my mission finally this video
and all the videos on this channel would
not exist at all if it were not for my
amazing supporters on patreon in
particular I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow p patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you so much y'all
Rock and if you out there enjoy the
videos that I create and you'd like to
see more of them the best way to make
that happen is to go sign up to support
my work on patreon you can do that over
at
patreon.com Factor pooy where you can
also get access to a whole host of
really awesome rewards so go check that
out please and thank you and if you
enjoyed this flow session I would highly
recommend you check out some of my other
flow sessions I will include a link to a
playlist of those videos down in the
description as well as up in uh up on
screen as you're watching this video on
YouTube thank you so much for watching
make sure to get out and flow yourself
today and I'll see you with a new video
real soon take care now peace